l'union libre être livre des députés
socialistes veulent la codifier et à
l'image de l'autre union le mariage il
propose la mise au point d'un contrat
d'union civile qui comporterait
évidemment des droits inexistant
aujourd'hui mais aussi des devoirs
béatrice nivois avait poggio en france 2
millions de couples vivant en union
libre un enfant sur trois naît hors
mariage pour cela qu'ils ont refusé un
engagement rigide un projet de contrat
d'union civile se propose de leur donner
des garanties notamment bénéficié de la
sécurité sociale de l'autre ou en cas de
décès ne pas débourser des droits
successoraux plus importants que ceux
des couples légitimes
je travaille à la disposition
législative qui permettrait à ceux qui
vivent ensemble sans être mariés et
pouvoir régler plus facilement quelques
problèmes pratiques de la vie
quotidienne comme acheter ou louer un
logement sans nous régler les problèmes
de file des chutes et nyon lors que l'un
des deux est faible les dispositions
pratiques juridiques qui permettraient
l'égalité des droits pour toutes du même
coup les couples homosexuels
bénéficierait de tous ces avantages et
verrait leur union reconnu ce qu'il
demande depuis des années et là commence
le vrai débat alors s'il faut faire une
loi pour mot sexuelle ou d'un droit pour
homosexuels
moi je veux bien mais c'est certainement
pas le même que pour un homme et une
femme qui vivent sans bien sûr que ça
concerne des homosexuels et des années d
hétérosexuels mais ça peut considérer
qu'on concernés par exemple de vieilles
dames qui vivent ensemble tout
simplement parce que parce que la
solitude c'est difficile et puis ça
coûte moins cher d'avoir un seul
logement
sur les neuf articles de ce projet
concerne les enfants il prévoit
l'autorité parentale conjointe
là aussi les détracteurs du texte donne
la réponse il ya deux solutions ou bien
les gens qui vivent hors mariage
souhaite continuer à vivre par mariage
ou bien espagne nous marier le mariage
ça sert à ça
cet après midi les députés du groupe
socialiste ont étudié le projet mais de
là à le présenter à l'assemblée il y
encore un pas qu'ils n'ont pas franchi
tant il est vrai que ce projet
bouleverserait plus la morale que le
cadre juridique
en tout cas le contrat d'union civile ne
prévoit pas comme le mariage une clause
la fidélité mais moi je voulais te
parler des vacances à projets de
vacances projet de couple ans même s'ils
entrevoient en l'avenir à 2 à toujours
été un peu compliqué pour laurent et
stéphane un couple qui au regard de la
loi et d autres vies au seuil de la
marginalité
actuellement notre couple n'est pas
reconnu bon et bien vis-à-vis de
l'extérieur
lorsqu'on se présente ou lorsqu'on
remplit des papiers on coche dans la
classe célibataire on est célibataire
vis-à-vis de l'extérieur et ça c'est pas
vrai ça correspond pas à la réalité et
ça voudrait dire quelque part que notre
couple est marginal or nous on n'est pas
des marginaux
le contrat d'union social va donner un
statut juridique à leur couple un statut
qui leur permettra de faire du projet à
deux ça permet d'avoir notamment à
droite robail commun lorsqu'on cherche
un appartement vis-à-vis de la banque
aussi ça permet
se présenter en tant que couple
fiscalité héritage ou tout simplement
possibilité de suivre son partenaire en
cas de mutation
et puis et surtout obligation de secours
et d'assistance
j'ai des obligations à son à son égard
donc c'est très fort comme geste
l'un vers l'autre quoi puis c'est aussi
un geste vers la société s'est montré
que qu'on est bien ensemble que on
s'aime et puis que et puis que c'est
comme ça et puis c'est bien c'est plutôt
sympathique quan un contrat d'union pas
de mariage exclut aussi l'adoption où
l'insémination artificielle ce contrat
soleil qui républicain sans distinction
de sexe alors ça peut être des couples
sexuée homosexuels hétérosexuels ça peut
être également des étudiants qui
partagent une chambre des personnes
âgées des hébergeants et d'héberger des
situations tout à fait multiples et
diverses
le contrat d'union se fera en mairie
devant un officier d'état civil
dès le vote de la loi elisabeth guigou
le ministre de la justice a annoncé la
création d'un contrat d'union sociale il
s'agit de donner un cadre juridique aux
couples homosexuels notamment ces
couples qui n'ont pas accès au mariage
c'était l'un des engagements de la
campagne électorale valérie fournier
jean paul chaussée non il est sa vie de
couple va changer juridiquement le
contrat l'union sociale va reconnaître
l'existence légale de tous les couples
homosexuels
un contrat qui mettra fin à des
situations souvent douloureuse en cas de
décès on n'assistera plus enfin à des
situations familiales conflictuelles ou
le partenaire et et pourrait se
retrouver ce pôle il est totalement par
la film de l'autre le nouveau
gouvernement a donc tenu sa promesse
électorale
l'union hors mariage de deux personnes
aura maintenant à 7 juridique mais les
associations homosexuelles compte bien
être vigilante car le contrat d'union
social n'inclut pas le cas des couples
binationaux ni celui des fonctionnaires
en cas de mutation d'un des deux
partenaires
et puis surtout ce contrat n'est pas un
mariage si on se base sur un principe
d'égalité des droits
demain on réclamera le droit au mariage
par exemple où le droit à l'adoption
le droit la stimulation artificielle les
femmes célibataires particulier de
lesbiennes et cetera et cetera un peu à
l'image de ce qui se passe dans les
autres pays européens avec le contrat
d'union sociale la france n'y suis pas
encore les exemples américains et
surtout scandinaves où les mariages
homosexuels sont autorisés mais elle
reconnaît aujourd'hui leur alliance de
coeur le pacte civil de solidarité les
affrontements verbaux se multiplient
entre les pour et les contre le groupe
socialiste de l'assemblée nationale
s'est prononcé aujourd'hui pour une
extension de la plupart des dispositions
de ce pacte aux frères et soeurs mais
cet ajout qui pourrait prendre la forme
d'un amendement dès vendredi n'est pas
de nature à calmer les oppositions
reportage jean baptiste prédit philippe
deslandes
tu es discute rarement de l'évolution
des moeurs avec le projet de pacte civil
de solidarité
ils sont servis du coup pour la rentrée
l'assemblée s'offrent un débat passionné
un nouveau statut accordé aux couples
hétéro ou homosexuel et le clivage
gauche-droite repart à il y a un projet
qui donne des droits à des coupes et qui
n'enlève aucun autre droit à d'autres
couples ceux qui ont choisi le mariage
je vois pas ce qui pourrait faire naître
polémique compassion je vois que la
droite à la veille de l'examen du pacs
en séance plénière se réveille
inspiré par les porteurs de crucifix les
grenouilles de bénitier et autres sectes
religieuses qui cherchent plutôt à à
défendre je ne sais quelle conception de
la famille qui en tout cas n'est plus de
mise aujourd'hui dans l'opposition va
s'opposer en bloc au nom de la famille
en dénonçant certains aspect supposé du
texte je ne suis pas favorable au
mariage des homosexuels s'est récemment
dit le mariage est une conquête de la
république et je suis attaché la
république je suis un élu de banlieue
je sais ce que ça veut dire que le coût
social de la décomposition de la famille
et ce texte au lieu de le résoudre va
encore aggraver les conséquences de la
crise de la famine la tension monte à
l'assemblée à droite seul le député
appelle roselyne bachelot accepte le
texte et a même proposé de l'étendre aux
membres d'une même famille mais vendredi
l'opposition va déposer plus de 500
amendements
ce devait être un débat de société ce
sera d'abord une bataille de procédure
apparaît maintenant de pacs le pacte de
solidarité
est-ce que vous appuyer pleinement cette
loi est ce que vous en êtes totalement
convaincus ou est-ce qu'au fond vous
êtes prêt l'aménager où est-ce qu'ils
avaient vraiment nécessité de faire une
loi dès qu'est ce que vous avez évolué
vous même là dessus mais le problème de
mon évolution est pas tellement à ce
n'était clairement pas ce que c'est vrai
de beaucoup de gens oui alors oui mais
alors à travers les années si vous
voulez mais dans la campagne législative
j'avais dit que des mesures devraient
être
reese là pour régler par des mesures
dans leur fiscale dans l'ordre social
dans l'ordre successoral des successions
des problèmes que vivent des personnes
qui vivent en commun qui vivent qui ont
une vie commune et qui ne sont pas soit
des hommes et des femmes mariées acquis
qu'ils ne choisissent pas le mariage ou
acquis d'une certaine façon le mariage
est interdit parce que le mariage ou la
famille ce sont des institutions
particulière et qu'il fallait régler ses
problèmes
c'est ce que nous faisons et je dois
dire que si l'opposition qui a choisi
dans cette affaire n'ont pas de de
s'opposer vraiment par conviction à ces
mesures que nous préconisons parce que
je pense que dans son for intérieur
et quand on discute avec elle sauf
peut-être des milieux de la droite a été
l'homme de la droite prix enfin vous les
avez montré vous avez montré en quoi il
était lié à une secte brésilienne
attendent maintenant en face aux sons
des éléments qui sont quand même souvent
très à droite
nous nous rencontrons beaucoup de nos
collègues qu'ils comprennent que ces
mesures doivent être prises
ils ont choisi de s'opposer parce qu'il
faut s'opposer
moi je crois au contraire qu'il devrait
y avoir des sujets de société qu'on
aborde sans passion pour les faire
avancer
et c'est eux qui créent des problèmes là
où il n'y en a pas le pacs est un pat
c'est un contrat entre deux personnes
certaines effectivement peuvent être et
sont homosexuels et ont besoin de voir
régler un certain nombre de problèmes de
leur vie commune ne cherchons pas à le
cacher c'est fait aussi pour ça certains
ne sont pas dans cette situation et ont
besoin de choisir ses formes de contrats
pour régler des problèmes de leur vie
commune
si on n'y avait pas mis autant de
passion je pense que on aurait avancé
avec beaucoup moins de troubles mais
entre vous disiez justement pendant ma
campagne mais dit il faudra prendre des
dispositions des mesures alors aux roses
demande justement pourquoi une loi qui
suscite tant de passion parce qu'on fait
rien c'est une passion dans notre pays
pourquoi ne pas avoir pris des
dispositions pour changer le code des
impôts
pour les droits de succession et ça
serait peut-être pas c'est plus
tranquille maintenant et dans une
proposition de loi qui part actuelle au
lieu d'une loi opéra d'abord d'abord
c'était trop poussé cette loi ne part
pas du tout dans tout dans tous les sens
être abordée demain présenté par
elisabeth guigou et les choses vont se
dérouler à mon sens normalement cette
loi sera votée elle est comprise par les
français parce qu'ils comprennent que en
rien cela ne menace l'institution
familiale
le mariage c'est une institution de la
société la famille ce sont des parents
d'hommes et femmes avec des enfants
et là il ne s'agit pas de cela il n'y a
ni le devoir du mariage ni les
privilèges si l'on peut dire du mariage
juste en particulier vous savez très
bien que l'adoption est interdit et leur
restera que la procréation artificielle
permettant donc la filiation est
également interdite et le restera donc
je pense que c'est un projet qui prend
en compte une évolution de la société
que les français qui ont beaucoup de bon
sens le comprennent et que cela se
passait en afrique quand les autorités
religieuses n'a pas la droite les
autorités religieuses et des différentes
confessions manifeste énormément de
réserve et disent craindre sûrement
pense craindre craig réellement qu'ils
s'agissent selon les mots qu'ils
emploient soit de mariage be ce soit de
ce mariage soit d'une étape vers le
mariage homosexuel est ce que ça ne vous
trouble pas cette conjonction des
institutions religieuses de confessions
différentes
non cela ne trouble pas parce que les
confessions religieuses et les
institutions religieuses ont une mission
particulière je la comprends je la
respecte
elle porte un message qui est un message
de la révélation qui est aussi un
message du dogme était un message de
valeur naturellement ces messages sont
absolument essentielles à notre vie en
société mais je vais prendre un autre
exemple vous admettrez que depuis la loi
veil de 1960
16 je crois que c'est 76
les progrès de la contraception y
compris l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse ce qu'on appelait l'avortement
tout cela est passé dans la société je
vous ferai remarquer que les grandes
confessions et en particulier l'église
catholique ont été courts le sont
toujours élevés et ça n'a pas empêché le
fait que c'est quelque chose d'admis
tout à fait désormais dans les sociétés
démocratiques qu'il faut comprendre que
les églises ont un message particulier
qu'il faut respecter mais qui ne peut
pas inspiré entièrement la vie sociale
même si ça contribue au combat des hauts
des bas des idées fassions une question
qui se pose est ce que le pacs
n'entraîne pas une espèce d'engrenages
qui ferait que demain le mariage
homosexuel sera effectivement autorisé
et puis après demain l'adoption des
enfants par des couples homosexuels est
ce que ce n'est pas dans la logique du
pacs non absolument pas c'est justement
parce qu'il est quelque chose d'autre
parce qu'il n'est pas ce mariage que
vous n'avez pas du tout vous à le
construire comme un engrenage la
position du gouvernement est claire
l'acceptation par l'opinion elle est que
nous que le parlement contribue à régler
des problèmes de vie commune
les problèmes de succession des
problèmes fiscaux des problèmes sociaux
elle n'est en rien justement que l'on
construise une sorte de mariage bis voir
le mariage homosexuel si vous voulez
ciblé 7 cette catégorie de la population
et donc nous nous en tiendrons l'a
totalement alors débat partir de demain
puis jusqu'au 13 octobre quand le pacs
selon la droite le débat sur le pacte
civil de solidarité s'ouvre demain à
l'assemblée texte qui a été précédée
d'une polémique sur la défense des
valeurs du mariage dans l'opposition les
avis en fait sont partagés tout le monde
n'est pas contre le pacs reportage eric
thiebaut et clémence eugène christine
boutin en a fait son combat
porte-drapeau de la droite conservatrice
elle mène une véritable croisade contre
le pacs elle défendra 150 amendements
car pour elle et ses amis le pacte civil
de solidarité n'est qu'un mariage
homosexuel qui ne dirait pas son nom
je ne suis pas favorable au mariage des
homosexuels parce que je ne crois pas
qu'il soit bon d'ériger en norme
l'homosexualité l'homosexualité est par
nature la difficulté d'atteindre l'autre
dans sa différence
et quand on ne peut pas atteindre
l'autre dans la différence c'est
l'exclusion le libéral renaud dutreil
est à la tête d'un groupe de 29 jeunes
députés qui développe les mêmes
arguments il estime le mariage menacé et
craignent déjà que les homosexuels
réclament le droit d'adoption
face à ce conservatisme les chefs de la
droite edouard balladur philippe séguin
ou alain juppé préfèrent se taire c'est
le rpr patrick devedjian qui sera leur
porte-parole mais lui il s'en tient les
arguments strictement juridique ce que
propose avec ce petit gadget la du pacs
les socialistes un truc qui tient pas la
route et qui présente beaucoup plus
d'inconvénients que d'avantagés
seule la député gaulliste auzines
bachelot devrait voter pour le pacs elle
dénonce les arguments caricaturaux
développé par les conservateurs de son
propre camp
c'est à contre tous à ce contrat qui
exprime une solidarité entre deux
personnes en dehors de toute connotation
sexuelle
ce n'est pas un mariage homosexuel bien
entendu d'autres députés de l'opposition
comme alain madelin approuve
discrètement le pacs mais il préfère
s'abstenir ou simplement ne pas venir en
séance
bref la droite laissera ses
représentants les plus conservateurs
monopolisé la parole durant le débat
depuis ce matin 9h c'est un débat
passionné qui s'est ouvert à l'assemblée
nationale les députés se penchent sur le
pacs le pacte civil de solidarité qui
vise à accorder aux couples aux
personnes en communauté de vie un statut
légal
quelques 900 amendements ont été déposés
principalement par l'opposition le
rapporteur ce matin s'est défendu de
toute arrière pensée
dominique martinaud benoît durand
c'est très irrité que le rpr envisager
ce matin l'ouverture de ce débat sur le
pacs le gouvernement n'est pas content
d'avoir une opposition il a dit il
de la faire travailler jusqu'à 7 heures
du matin et par conséquent nous qui
avons au rpr nos journées parlementaires
à menton ça va être un véritable
marathon
eh bien je ne pensons que ce n'était pas
une bonne moyens un bon moyen
en tous les cas de respecter
l'opposition ce n'est pas un bon moyen
de travailler non plus pour faire
avancer un sujet de société qui est
difficile et délicat face à une
quinzaine de députés de gauche et une
trentaine à droite très remonté
le garde des sceaux a réaffirmé que le
pacs n'était pas un mariage bis mais une
nouvelle forme de solidarité
c'est un texte qui ouvre des droits
nouveaux sans en supprimer
il est une avancée sociale parce qu'il
encourage la stabilité
il est une avancée morale parce qu'ils
encouragent la solidarité à droite
chahut bien sûr on ne veut rien entendre
décidé à jouer l'opposition jusqu'au
bout avec toutes les procédures
habituelles d'obstruction pour tenter de
rejeter ce texte
j'ai une position très simple dans cette
affaire consiste à dire le pacs n'est
pas la réponse aux problèmes que pose
notre société
ce qu'il faut c'est rénover le mariage
et adapter le droit de façon à l'adapter
à l'évolution notre société à la notion
de couple en france mais sur les bancs
de la droite ce matin en haute et
certaines absences ce très rare il est
vrai qu'ils approuvent ce texte comme
roselyne bachelot cité d'ailleurs en
exemple ce matin par le ministre de la
justice
bonsoir coup de théâtre à l'assemblée
nationale et première défaite pour la
gauche dont les députés n'étaient pas
assez nombreux pour défendre dans
l'hémicycle le pacte civil de solidarité
face à l'offensive d'une droite
remobiliser déclaré irrecevable
aujourd'hui la proposition ne devrait
pas tarder cependant à revenir au
parlement dominique martinaud benoît
véran la séance de l'après midi avait
mal commencé
le ministre est en retard huées de la
droite surexcité elle est sûre de faire
adopter sa motion d'irrecevabilité la
gauche dans l'hémicycle est minoritaire
au perchoir
yves cochet manifestement troublé
procèdent au vote et pour qui et contre
l'exception d'irrecevabilité n'est pas
adopté c'est le lapsus l'opposition se
transforme en furie je reprends ma
parole
l'exception d'irrecevabilité est adoptée
rectification explosion de joie à droite
débandade à gauche
du jamais vu la droite triomphe c'est sa
première victoire contre lionel jospin
malgré cet appel du premier ministre
hier soir aujourd'hui ses troupes ne
sont pas là c'est donc pour lui un échec
personnel
donc c'est la première grande défaite de
lionel jospin depuis qu'il est premier
ministre
les autres suivront je pense que c'est
un échec pour la majorité qui est trop
sûre d'elle
on ne peut pas gouverner un pays en
s'appuyant sur l'idée qu'on a été
majoritaire une fois et qu'on l'ait
définitivement à gauche on est loin de
pavoiser
et communistes et socialistes refusent
de battre leur coulpe l'heure n'est pas
à distribuer des bons des mauvais points
l'heure a constaté qu'il a manqué
effectivement là une majorité qu'on la
retrouvera dans la prochaine période
j'en suis certain et alors si nous avons
reçu un petit un petit coup et bien
croyez bien que cela nous rendre encore
plus forts et plus déterminés
chez les verts on n'hésite pas à parler
de vendredi noir pour la gauche
plurielle
je suis accablé je me sens un peu
honteux de voir que la majorité
plurielle n'a pas été capable de faire
passer un texte dont elle était à
l'origine accablement aussi chez les
députés initiateurs de la loi
mais c'est promis dès ce soir un nouveau
texte doit être déposé
il pourrait être examiné les 24 et 25
octobre prochains
nicolas sarkozy bonsoir nous allons
évidemment revenir sur ce coup de
théâtre à l'assemblée
j'imagine évidemment que l'opposition se
félicite donc le pacs a été retiré il
n'y aura pas de débat en tout cas pour
l'instant
vous souhaitez qu'il y ait un débat dans
l'avenir où vous souhaitez carrément que
le pacs passe aux oubliettes
non mais il faut d'abord dire que c'est
très bien pour monsieur jospin qui se
rend compte que la démocratie c'est une
opposition et majorité qui peut pas
faire toujours ce qu'il veut surtout
lorsque ça ne va contre le bon sens
deuxièmement c'est une interrogation où
étaient les députés socialistes soient
une vienne pas l'assemblée nationale ce
qui n'est pas bien
soit ils n'étaient pas d'accord sur le
texte qu'ils avaient eux-mêmes présentés
dans ce cas là ils ont menti à ce qu'il
prétendait défendre et représenter les
écoutera on va pas préjuger de
s'agissant du pacs maintenant le
gouvernement s'est pris les pieds dans
le tapis
c'était un monstre juridique nous ce que
nous avons voulu faire c'est l'idée que
l'on se fait de la famille depuis des
années et des années
alors ne voulant pas que nous touche
mais c'est sa lancée dès maintenant je
vous donnais tout cela parle mais avant
d'aller au fond parce que c'est vrai que
c'est un problème de fond on pourra
d'ailleurs pas faire le débat
complètement ce soir vous avez gagné là
sur une bataille de procédure vous
imaginez bien que pour les citoyens ce
n'est pas satisfaisant
madame excusez-moi de quel citoyen parle
et vous vous pensez vous pensez que tous
les citoyens et oeil a été été pour le
pacs pas du tout mais je pense que le d
mauritel lettres là où peut-être faut-il
qu'il est basé le débat nous l'avons
mené la question préalable a été
défendue d'excellente manière qu'est ce
qu'elle est le problème aujourd'hui et
je veux notamment m'adresser puisque
j'ai vu dans les différents reportages
un certain nombre de réactions de la
communauté homosexuelle
il ya des problèmes qui se posent aux
homosexuels personne ne le conteste
personne et surtout pas nous nous
voulons nous attaquer à leur liberté
nous disons simplement une chose simple
et j'espère compréhensible par tous ceux
qui nous regardent
on peut résoudre les problèmes des
homosexuels au regard de la donation au
regard des successions dans un couple
homosexuel en touchant aux mesures
fiscales
ce que nous ne voulons pas c'est que
l'on touche à la famille à notre code de
la famille et que l'on crée un vrai faux
sous mariage si le gouvernement nous dit
il s'agit de résoudre les problèmes des
homosexuels par le biais de la fiscalité
nous discuterons bien volontiers s'il
veut porter atteinte à la famille mais
quelle son mariage en le 24 octobre
prochain où il y aura débat à
l'assemblée
voilà je suis désolé je craque monsieur
jospin ne connaissent pas la procédure
parlementaire car le 24 octobre
c'est pas la date pour les socialistes
car soit le texte est représenté sous
forme de proposition de loi et la
prochaine niche parlementaire pour les
socialistes c'est en février soit le
texte est présenté sous forme de projet
de loi à l'initiative du gouvernement et
dans ce cas là il doit passer par le
conseil d'état il doit passer devant la
chine parce que le gouvernement voulait
ficher les homosexuels il doit passer en
commission et il doit revenir à
l'assemblée nationale il suffit pas de
dunkerque
monsieur jospin qui sait tout sur tout
10 ça sera donc un jour donc vous
suffisent la colonnade il n'a lui pas du
tout madame d'envié répondre et les
débats nous sommes d'accord mais à une
procédure parlementaire savez-vous dans
une démocratie à des votes
qu'est ce qui s'est passé à l'assemblée
une majorité de la représentation
nationale a dit noah ce texte
donc on reviendra pour discuter de ce
texte dans d'autres conditions qu'ils
respecteront les règles de la démocratie
ces autres conditions
si je vous comprends bien je vais
révéler aux réformes fiscales mais palm
année en octobre ses mentors de la fable
qu'il n'y aura pas de débat le 24
octobre à andrée on voudrait nous faire
dire qu'en deux semaines
il faut tout changer recommencer
pourquoi parce que les socialistes ont
été battus c'est ça qui est gênant alors
une deuxième
s'ils ont tout aussi simple est-ce que
vous pensez que ce projet devrait être
fait cette proposition de loi devrait
devenir un projet de loi que le
gouvernement prenne l'initiative de ce
débat qui au fond est un vrai débat de
société
non madame c'est un faux débat de
société on veut faire croire à la
communauté homosexuelle qu'on résoudra
leur problème en créant un faux mariage
sous mariage nous disons qu'il suffit
tient dans le cadre de la discussion
budgétaire que le gouvernement dépose
des amendements fiscaux pour résoudre
les problèmes de donations et
successions entre deux personnes
homosexuelles et à ce moment là il n'y a
plus de problème madame mais c'est si on
veut pas toucher à la famille alors on
fait comme ça si on veut toucher à la
famille on trouvera l'opposition unie
déterminer des très combative
on l'a compris le pacs ne concerne pas
exclusivement les homosexuels moi j'ai
pris quelques chiffres 2 millions de
personnes qui vivent en concubinage un
million de couples non mariés avec
enfants 39 % des naissances qui se font
hors mariage aujourd'hui c'est donc un
débat qui concerne je viens donc il
n'est pas du tout pas du tout qui
contexte qu'on a le droit de vivre en
concubinage qui est contre savez vous
madame qu'un enfant qui va naître dans
le cadre du pacs est ce que vous savez
qu'il n'aura pas la présomption de
paternité est ce que vous savez qu'une
femme unis dans le cadre du pacs n'aura
le droit ni à prestation compensatoire
ni à pension alimentaire en cas de
rupture de ce pacs est ce que c'est ça
qu'on veut
est ce que c'est ça les grands débats de
société de fragiliser la femme et
l'enfant dans vous savez c'est un débat
trop important pour qu'on s'en tienne à
quelques slogans avec nous pour évoquer
le pack c'est ce qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui à l'assemblée roselyne
bachelot monfort madame vous êtes député
rpr et vous avez une particularité dans
ce débat c'est que vous êtes le seul
député d'opposition qui est favorable à
ce texte
alors est ce qu'à votre avis qui s'est
passé aujourd'hui sa porte à un coup au
crédit du pacs ou pas je ne crois pas je
ne crois pas parce qu'il y à un
véritable débat de fond qui finalement
n'a pas encore eu lieu
et je lisais un sondage qui est paru
hier un sondage bva qui disait que 84 %
des jeunes de moins de 25 ans sont
favorables au pacs au pacte civil de
solidarité et jusqu'à 50 ans deux
français sur trois sont favorables au
pacs donc de toute façon aujourd'hui 2
main ou après demain il y aura un texte
qui s'appellera pacte civil de
solidarité qui s'appellera comme il
voudra mais qui concrétisera ce besoin
des français cela dit sur ce qui s'est
passé aujourd'hui est ce que vous pensez
que les socialistes ont fait preuve de
désinvolture ou de manque de courage
pour certains d'entre eux je crois que
s'ils me permettez cette vulgarité
lionel jospin sur ce sujet s'est
débrouillé comme un manche il a d'abord
refusé de faire un texte qu'ils soient
d'origine gouvernementale il a donc
laissé sur un texte aussi important on
l'a vu à travers le débat de société qui
s'est déroulé il a laissé un texte
d'initiative parlementaire dans ce qu'on
appelle une niche c'est à dire un texte
qui ne se discute pas en milieu de
semaine mais qui se discute en fin de
semaine et encore heureusement qu'il y
avait nos journées parlementaires sinon
la discussion aurait dû continuer le
samedi et le dimanche parce qu'il avait
pas beaucoup on a l'intention de se
mouiller sur ce texte accorde les
députés socialistes qui ne se sont pas
sentis mobiliser parce que leur chef a
agi avec beaucoup de lâcheté et pas
beaucoup de détermination et maintenant
ils en récoltent les fruits et la droite
la droite et très mobilisés contre ce
texte mise à part vous donc est ce que
vous pensez vraiment que le pacs menace
la famille telle qu'on la conçoit dans
ce pays depuis plusieurs siècles
non je ne crois pas je crois qu'il y a
eu ce qu'il ya news gars qui est ce
qu'il ya lieu de se réjouir de ce qui
s'est passé aujourd'hui quand on est
dans l'opposition non je ne crois pas
qu'il y a lieu de se réjouir ni d'un
côté ni de l'autre
parce que finalement il y a énormément
de gens à l'intérieur de l'opposition
qui va très bien ce texte qui me l'ont
dit qu'ils m'ont dit oui à des problèmes
où il faut trouver une solution et qui
s'y opposent parce qu'il faut bien s'y
opposer et puis de l'autre côté il ya
des députés socialiste ou de la gauche
plurielle qui ne sont pas favorable au
pacs et qui n'osent pas l'avouer et qui
ce soir ont voté un petit peu par leur
absence moi j'ai été très frappé j'ai
demandé qu'on me communique la liste des
maires de ma circonscription qui avait
voté vous savez le fameux appel les
mères contre le pacte civil de
solidarité
j'ai découvert avec stupéfaction qu'ils
avaient des maires socialistes de
masques de ma circonscription qui avait
voté contre le pacte civil
solidarité donc il faut pas en faire de
ce débat de société
un affrontement droite gauche quand nous
avons mis sur pied les lois très
important des lois de société qui est l
interruption volontaire de grossesse ont
quitté la contraception
on n'a pas dit aux députés de notre
majorité d'alors sur ce texte il faut
que vous veniez absolument tout le monde
pareil on veut voir qu'une tête on a
laissé la liberté de pensée parce que
c'était justement des textes de société
donc vous êtes en train de le dire
finalement qu'il ya beaucoup
d'hypocrisie des deux côtés c'est parce
que
finalement ce texte
traite principalement de l'homosexualité
même si on a un petit peu habillée
depuis et que ça fait encore un peu peur
dans électorale il ya plusieurs c'est
vrai que même le texte a été portée au
départ par des associations
d'homosexuels et puis on and on s'est
bien rendu compte tout au cours de ces
années parce que moi il ya pratiquement
dix ans que je m'occupe de ce dossier
que finalement des tas de personnes
on sent concerné j'ai déposé lors du
débat lors de la préparation du texte un
amendement sur les fratries pour que le
texte concerne les frères et soeurs qui
vivent ensemble
j'ai reçu des dizaines de lettres de
gens me disaient me disant mais oui on
vit ensemble on est inquiet on a besoin
d'exprimer cette solidarité entre nous
donc c'est vrai un texte qui part d'une
minorité mais dont l'ensemble de la
société saisie et finalement c'est ça
qui est important sur ce sur ce sujet
merci beaucoup roselyne bachelot le
retour du pacs après le fiasco de la
première discussion les députés ont
retrouvé un texte légèrement modifié
dans la majorité on a resserré les rangs
l'opposition en fait elle une affaire de
principe et elle a déposé plusieurs
centaines d'amendements à l'assemblée ce
soir valérie patton marc felix loin de
l'atmosphère passionné il y a trois
semaines christine boutin le premier
orateur de l'opposition a lancé son
réquisitoire contre le pacs un
discours-fleuve répétitif de quatre
heures devant un hémicycle bien garni
applaudissements de la droite quolibets
de la gauche
la députée udf accuse la majorité
plurielle d'ouvrir une brèche dans
l'institution du mariage et de la
famille
une fois qu'on sera pacsés si on est un
couple hétérosexuel on pourra pas
refuser l'adoption
on ne voit pas pourquoi les pacsés
homosexuels ne pourrait pas puisqu'ils
sont dans le même moule juridique ne
pourrait pas avoir l'adoption c'est
l'enjeu qu'est ce que c'est que ces
mascarades ses contorsions ces danses du
ventre de la gauche une gauche qui
s'attendaient à cette bataille frontale
et sans merci
annoncé par la droite en fin de journée
le garde des sceaux s'est chargé de
défendre l'engagement du gouvernement
le pacs ne change rien au droit actuel
de la famille car la seule cohabitation
de deux individus pacte ou non ne fait
pas une famille c'est donc
volontairement que le pacte est sans
effet sur les règles de la filiation de
l'autorité parentale et sur les droits
de l'enfant
certes les communistes et les verts
contestent l'extension du pacs aux
frères et soeurs mais il devrait voter
le texte comme un seul homme
toutefois pour préserver la sérénité des
débats le gouvernement est prêt à
attendre la fin du mois de novembre pour
faire voter ce pacs deuxième version de
quoi peut-être amadouer les plus modérés
de l'opposition qui savent déjà que les
jeux sont fait demain l'assemblée
nationale reprise du débat sur le pacs
le pacte civil de solidarité concernant
cette proposition de loi
il y à gauche comme à droite des voix
contradictoires ainsi une seule députée
de la droite parlementaire est favorable
au pacs elle est élue députée en terre
angevine
madame roselyne bachelot est catholique
et ne craint pas d'affronter une partie
de ses électeurs
portrait d'arnaud boutet et patrick
descheemaecker qu'a finalement nous ne
reconnaissons ici qu'une communauté la
république
l'émotion dans la voix et les larmes
dans l'hémicycle c'était le 7 novembre à
l'assemblée
roselyne bachelot seul contre tous ses
collègues de droite
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui madame la députée a retrouvé
le sourire dans les rues de la ville
son visage ne passe plus inaperçu
roselyne bachelot connaît la gloire
c'est vrai qu'il ya un sentiment de
reconnaissance mais qui a certainement
qui s'est décuplé depuis le débat sur le
pacte civil de solidarité
mais il lui faut maintenant convaincre
ses électeurs tous ceux qui se sentent
par tryde le problème est elle le reflet
de ses électeurs on peut s'interroger on
peut se poser la question et un électeur
at-il élus à députés pour défendre son
opinion personnelle ou pour les seuls
députés travailler en solo est une
grande question sur ses terres
catholiques
le pacte civil de solidarité passe mal
ici le combat de roselyne bachelot
réveille la droite
exemple dans ce restaurant où
l'opposition municipale udf rpr s'est
réuni et lorsqu'on évoque le sujet les
passions se déchaînent de répudiation
moi c'est après une vraie question c'est
à dire que du jour là mais en ce ce qui
est entre guillemets de chez soi on
laisse le plus faible en l'occurrence
l'enfant et son pacsé ou sap accès moi
je peux dire les enfants de quoi ils
sont malades dans la pathologie du
désamour
ils sont malades du divorce tel qu'il
existe dans notre pays
le deuxième point en ce qui concerne la
répudiation c'est 80 portant des niveaux
sont demandés par les femmes ce sont les
femmes qui ne supporte pas les mauvais
mariage
ce sont les femmes à qui on impose de
rester mariées demain la plus roses des
chiraquienne défendra une nouvelle fois
le pacs à l'assemblée et le combat ne
fait que commencer
la tension monte sur la scène politique
et cet après-midi la séance des
questions à l'assemblée nationale s'est
résumée à une empoignade entre le
gouvernement et l'opposition concernant
le dossier du pacs la députée rpr
christine boutin a même quitté
l'hémicycle en pleurs après une
altercation avec le premier ministre
reportage sur place dominique martinaud
joseph tual l'on s'adresse
c'est renaud muselier qui va créer
l'incident interpellant le premier
ministre il lui demande d'expliquer sa
méthode
lionel jospin tir alors tout asie
la loi sur l'audiovisuel la réforme sur
la justice enfin le pacs on attaquant
bille en tête l'opposition c'est le
choix de confier sa vision de ce
problème de société à une députée
marginal sur ces questions et
outrancière dans ses propos qui a créé
des problèmes
je suis droit dans mes bottes et il ya
celui qui préfère ajusté reprendre et
qui peut faire dire je suis souple dans
mes baskets touchés
christine boutin s'effondre en pleurs
hilarité sur les bancs des ministres au
fémina en se ressaisissant la députée
udf descend affronter le premier
ministre arrêté par les huissiers et ses
amis l invective lionel jospin essor
folle de rage
[Applaudissements]
première chose que j'aimerais dire c'est
qu'à un moment où le premier ministre
veut soi disant réhabiliter la place des
femmes dans la vie politique je laisse
au peuple de france le soin de juger de
ses paroles première chose
deuxième chose puisque je suis une
marginale j'appelle tous les français à
manifester à la fin du mois de janvier
contre le pacs a très bien fait soutenu
par tous les députés de l'opposition
chacun y va de son analyse politique sur
le dérapage du premier ministre et qui
soit énervé sur sa gauche c'est son
affaire mais qu'ils agressent
l'orientation nationale
c'est vraiment pas tolérable on a le
sentiment que ce gouvernement perd pied
et qu' il sert paul
parce que le calendrier parlementaire
lui échappe que le retrait de textes
apparaissent que le pacs dure trop
longtemps
à gauche on essaie de minimiser
l'incident et on juge très sévèrement la
réaction de la soi-disante victimes
moi ce que je souhaite c'est que
l'international on travaille
sérieusement et pour arrêter le
spectacle sa réaction personnelle de
fondre à la et malheureusement
totalement inadapté au monde de la
politique qui vaudrait mieux qu'elle
fasse autre chose
ambiance électrique à l'assemblée qui
laisse percer leur satisfaction de tous
les députés de droite comme de gauche
harassés par un calendrier législatif
inflationnistes c'est autour de ce grand
débat de société la défense de la
famille que se sont mobilisés ces
générations anti pacs des familles
entières portant des drapeaux et des
finances sous le soleil pour réclamer
donc le retrait du projet de loi avant
qu'il ne soit examiné par le sénat au
printemps
un défilé qui avait reçu le soutien de
plusieurs associations religieuses de
toutes confessions anne guéret à belpech
en tête du cortège
nos ancêtres les gaulois avaient invité
quatre hommes quatre hommes pour donner
à la manifestation une couleur
multiconfessionnelle général ils
montrent que justement on n'est pas
excellent
vous voyez qu'il ya toutes les
confessions monothéistes sur l'a7 une
raison importante car elle touche à
l'essentiel c'est-à-dire le noyau
familial
quatre hommes pour représenter les
grandes religions certes mais derrière
eux une majorité de familles catholiques
s'étaient rassemblés pour conduire la
croisade anti pacs
on a atteint quand on croit qu'on prenne
bilan et on est sûr que ruy profits
qu'ils puissent constituer les familles
et profiter des groupes véritablement
forts qui permettent pas ça c'était de
continuer bien témoigné nous que on est
content de passer pour le mariage et que
moi je peux réussir sa patrie soit
réussie cet après midi les familles
catholiques étaient venus en masse mais
les dignitaires religieux étaient
singulièrement absent le sénat tout
simplement supprimée de la proposition
de loi concernant le pacte civil de
solidarité le pacs un amendement du rpr
patrice gélard a été voté par 216 voix
contre 99 les sénateur rpr udf et
démocratie libérale ont rejeté un texte
où le pack serait pour eux je cite un
sou mariage qui ne veut pas dire son nom
reportage à vis timbert et marcel martin
dépassé les bornes
je suis une femme libre messieurs le
président de la commission des lois
même la traditionnelle ambiance feutrée
du sénat en a pris un coup
le pacs décidément ne saurait être
discuté sans passion ici
la droite s'est choisi un nouveau
porte-voix patrice gélard pas mécontent
de tenir la beauté cet élu rpr a fait
voter rien moins que la suppression du
pacs à la place une nouvelle définition
du concubinage
la preuve selon lui que le sénat c'est
s'adapter quand on dit que quelqu'un est
ringard c'est quelqu'un qui n'arrive pas
à s'adapter
la scène inverse c'est nous qui nous
adaptons et c'est l'assemblée nationale
qui a proposé quelque chose d'
irréaliste et irréalisable
le résultat c'est qu'elisabeth guigou se
lance dans une nouvelle bataille
après le marathon de l'assemblée
l'automne dernier retour à l'explication
de texte
le pacs ce sont de nouveaux droits en
matière de succession en matière fiscale
un plus pour les couples non mariés
notamment homosexuels je note c'est ça
qui me redonne si vous voulez malgré la
répétition que vous des arguments que
tout de même grâce à l'existence de ce
débat aujourd'hui très peu nombreuses
sont les personnes qui osent ostracisé
en tout cas dans les hémicycles est les
homosexuels et c'est bien la question
centrale qui aujourd'hui fait débat au
sénat
un couple peut-il être reconnue dès lors
qu'il unit deux personnes quel que soit
leur sexe il y a des concubins
hétérosexuels et c'est la majorité et il
y à un concubinage homosexuel et il est
temps de le reconnaître expressis verbis
ça ne sert à rien ces précautions dans
les tribunes réservées au public
la députée christine boutin elle a pu
assister ce soir au rejet du pacs par le
sénat projet de pure forme dans dix
jours
l'assemblée nationale rétablira le texte
en france la droite est agité par une
nouvelle polémique à propos du pacs le
week-end dernier certains jeunes
militants se sont en effet élevées
contre les positions défendues par
christine boutin en demandant une
modernisation le discours semble avoir
été entendu au rpr à l'udf en revanche
la députée se dit soutenu par les
leaders du parti eric thybaud alexandre
dupont christine boutin ne renonce pas
ses larmes ont séché depuis le débat sur
le pacs à l'assemblée nationale et
justement elle en a fait un livre les
larmes de la république
certes elle se dit peiné par les propos
tenus contre elle ce week-end mais elle
affirme aussitôt que la position de
l'udf contre le pacte civil de
solidarité n'a pas changé certain c'est
qu'à la fois françois bayrou au fil de
ste blazy
et anne marie idrac ont tenu à me
téléphoner hier pour me manifester leur
soutien et me dire combien ma position
était celle du groupe et qu'il n'y avait
pas de propos homophobes
christine boutin accuse à mots couverts
les chefs de l'udf de tenir un double
langage suivant les circonstances et
pour bien enfoncer le clou elle brandit
les mots de soutien de ses collègues
comme autant de bons points aux airs
faire l'affairé plus simple
nicolas sarkozy a pu facilement adoucir
son discours contre le pacs car personne
n'avait tenu de propos outranciers alors
roselyne bachelot peut aujourd'hui
affirmer que ses collègues la rejoignent
petit à petit tiers des électeurs de
moins de 35 ans était favorable au pacte
civil de solidarité et j'avais dit que
finalement la droite ne remercierai dans
quelques années d'avoir pris les
positions que j'avais adopté lors du
débat sur le pacte civil de solidarité
je pensais qu'il nous fallait quelques
années je pensais pas qu'il faudrait
simplement quelques semaines pour en
arriver là
toutefois le rpr comme l'udf à quelques
exceptions près votre encontre le pacs
en dernière lecture à l'assemblée
nationale
bref derrière l'apparence du discours la
droite cherche encore le chemin de la
rénovation aux termes de la loi le pacs
ou pactes civils de solidarité est un
contrat conclu par deux personnes
majeures de sexe différent ou de même
sexe
ce contrat a pour objet d'organiser leur
vie commune
un contrat qui doit faire l'objet d'une
déclaration conjointe au greffe du
tribunal d'instance en cas de rupture
une seule volonté suffit à rompre le
contrat toujours auprès du greffe du
tribunal
les deux conjoints deviennent solidaires
de leur dette
au bout de deux ans de vie commune le
couple pacsé peut prétendre à un
abattement sur les droits de succession
d'environ 300 mille francs après 3 ans
de concubinage
les conjoints font l'objet d'une
imposition commune sur leurs revenus
comme n'importe quel couple marié ces
deux personnes gagnent à peu près les
mêmes
longtemps ça ne changera strictement
rien par contre s'il a des membres du
pacs n'est pas n'a pas de revenus et que
l'autre l'un seulement à les revenus et
bien les revenus de ce couple seront
cette fois taxés avec deux par le
quotient au lieu d'une semaine par vous
avez donc c'est beaucoup plus
intéressant effectivement côté social le
partenaire qui ne pourraient avoir accès
à la sécurité sociale pourra bénéficier
de celles de son concubin
les deux sont également protégés par le
code du travail dans la fonction
publique le principe de rapprochement
géographique des conjoints éloigné
s'applique aux couples pacsés en matière
de logement le transfert du bail devient
possible notamment en cas de décès pour
le conjoint survivant
enfin la notion de concubinage doit
faire son entrée dans le code civil
un concubinage élargi aux couples
homosexuels c'est fait le pacte civil de
solidarité a été définitivement votée à
l'assemblée nationale cet après-midi 315
voix pour 249 contre et 4 abstentions
dont celle notable d'alain madelin et de
philippe seguin
la ministre de la justice s'est engagé à
tout faire pour que le pacs puisse en
pratique existait avant la fin de
l'année mais outre les appels au
président de la république lancé par la
députée udf anti pacs christine boutin
l'opposition compte sur le conseil
constitutionnel pour amender ou corriger
la loi comme l'expliqué arnaud boutet et
luc bachofen devant leur clavier de vote
électronique les députés au grand
complet attendre le signe quelques
secondes plus tard c'est fait le texte
est enfin voté pour 315 249,9 semblait
nationale adopté la loi sur le pacs
soulagement à gauche après un an de
bataille parlementaire et 2007 161
amendements déposés
mais dans l'opposition on ne s'avoue pas
encore vaincu plusieurs recours vont
être déposé devant le conseil
constitutionnel et notamment sur ce que
la droite appelle le fichage des
personnes
il est fondé sur premièrement une
atteinte aux droits de l'homme
qui est particulièrement grave puisque
la loi a pour objet d'obliger les
homosexuels a déclaré leurs pratiques
pour pouvoir bénéficier de nouveaux
droits c'est une atteinte au secret de
la vie privée
la droite juge également que les
gratifications fiscal du pacs sont
contraires au principe d'égalité
mais pour les spécialistes du droit ces
recours ne sont pas sûr d'aboutir
je crois que la loi sur le pacs est une
loi j'allais dire un peu hors normes
c'est une loi sur la vie personnelle
c'est une loi sur l'évolution sociale
c'est une loi sur les couples quelle que
soit la nature de ses coûts c'est donc
une loi pour laquelle les références
juridiques sont très très difficile à
trouver à partir de sa saisine le
conseil constitutionnel dispose d'un
mois pour se prononcer
la bataille du pacs n'est pas encore
terminée si le mariage vous effraie
rassurez vous il n'y a plus d'obstacle à
l'entrée en vigueur du pacs le conseil
constitutionnel a jugé conforme à la
constitution tout en émettant quelques
réserves elisabeth guigou se réjouit
espère que le premier pacte civil de
solidarité sera signé avant la fin de
l'année satisfaction aussi du collectif
pour le pacs qui salue à la fois un
choix politique est une innovation
juridique et being human
le conseil constitutionnel a déclaré les
dispositions qui lui étaient déférée
conforme à la constitution
saisi par 213 députés d'opposition et
115 sénateurs le conseil constitutionnel
a donc tranché la loi sur le pacs n'est
donc pas en désaccord avec les principes
de la constitution
mais le conseil a émis quelques réserves
ainsi il rappelle notamment que seuls
les couples hétéros pourront bénéficier
de l'aide médicale à la procréation
assistée
cette décision met fin à dix ans de
controverses d'hésitations et de
violents échanges dans les couloirs de
l'assemblée celle qui fut la plus
acharnée contre le pacte christine
boutin ne s'avoue pas encore vaincu pour
l'instant ce qui m'intéresse c'est de
savoir ce que va faire président de la
république
jeudi kyla l'article 10 qui donne la
possibilité de faire appel au parlement
pour une nouvelle délibération
je demande solennellement au président
de la république d'user de ce pouvoir
constitutionnel que lui donne l'article
beau joueur le porte-parole de
démocratie libérale a simplement
regretté cette décision je suis très
triste de voir qu'on impose à la société
française un texte sur le plan des
principes aussi dangereux aussi inutiles
et aussi mal monté sur le plan juridique
je le regrette profondément à gauche le
ré tourisme me sens et on pense déjà à
la suite devrait pouvoir enregistrer les
premiers plaques sont maintenant très
rapidement et peut être d'ici la fin de
l'année c'est désormais au président de
la république de promulguer la loi
quand le pacs a été votée tout s'est
fait très vite manuel olivier vivaient
ensemble depuis deux ans il avait envie
de légaliser leur union mais pour la
beauté et la force du symbole pas pour
les avantages qu'ils allaient avec
car dans les faits leur statut de pacsés
n'a pas changé grand chose ou si peu qui
gênent mutuelle obligatoire et j'ai pu
prendre manuel avec moi nous avons task
le que le pacs donc on a économisé 2003
mutuelle par an plus tard quand leur
pack sera trois ans ils pourront aussi
éventuellement décider de faire une
déclaration de revenus commune mais pour
le reste la loi ne présente que très peu
de bénéfices concrets pour beaucoup de
lourdeur et d'imprécisions la volonté
délibérée de ne pas pouvoir prêter le
flanc à une quelconque comparaison avec
le mariage abouti un choix qui n'était
certainement pas le meilleur
juridiquement parlant notamment dès que
des biens sont en jeu alors que les
couples mariés ont le choix entre un
régime de communauté ou de séparation de
biens
le régime de l'indivision par défaut
s'impose aux pacsés tous les biens
acquis par l'un ou l'autre pendant le
pacs meubles voitures ou actions sont
supposés appartenir aux deux mêmes sans
volonté explicite de leur part et c'est
là où commencent les litiges en cas de
rupture de pacs la séparation comme
celle que vit cet homme peut alors être
très mal vécu
quand vous voyez la penderie est à lui
donc il l'a remporté
à l'admission l'estimé que c'était la
nuit et tout ce que contient cet
appartement est aujourd'hui objet de
conflit entre les deux hommes nous avons
été pacsée pendant effectivement à peu
près trois mois et la fin difficile
c'est donc une histoire d'amour qui
finit mal avec en prime un flou
juridique qui envenime la situation
alors qu'ils étaient encore pacs et
frédéric et son ami ont acheté une
voiture et il est parti avec donc il a
déposé plainte pour le vol des clés
donc en fait la voiture d'après mon
avocat nous appartient à tous les deux
donc ce serait plutôt moi qui devraient
réclamer la voiture une semaine sur deux
ou un jour sur deux où est un grand flou
d'autant que l'assurance était à mon nom
la carte grise aux siens donc c'est vrai
que c'est assez
frédéric fériés n'est pas pour autant
dégoûté du pacs
les couples homosexuels n'ont pas
d'autre choix pour entériner leur union
mais la prochaine fois il s'assurera de
faire préciser chaque point du contrat
par un notaire à moins que d'ici là la
loisne et évoluer après les états unis
on reparle du mariage homosexuel en
france il ya le débat de principe il a
souvent été évoquée mais c'est le débat
juridique qui est maintenant ouvert un
groupe de juristes a créé en effet un
collectif
il estime qu'aucun élément du code civil
ne s'oppose ces mariages et plusieurs
élus à paris notamment se disent prêts à
célébrer de telles unions dossier signé
gaël chauvin laurent dit un regard
tendre c'est tout ce que ce père mais
jérôme quand il est en public avec
sylvain le couple vit ensemble depuis
plus d'un an
et s'il rêve aujourd'hui de mariage
c'est que le pacs seule reconnaissance
officielle possible de leur union n'est
pas une solution satisfaisante
si nous sommes pacsés en cas de décès
sylvain peut très bien se retrouver à la
porte du jour au lendemain c'est ma
famille décide de l'orne expulsé ça
s'est déjà vu notamment dans les années
les plus noires données les plus loin du
sida ça existe encore et le pacs n'a pas
permis de répondre à cette question
alors que le mariage le pourrait autre
limite le pacs n'est pas reconnue en
dehors de l'hexagone
il ne permet pas non plus l'adoption des
droits qu'apporterait le mariage s'il
était légal
c'est justement le cheval de bataille de
ce juriste pour lui le mariage
homosexuel n'est interdit par aucune loi
à l'époque de napoléon
c'était tellement évident que les
couples étaient hétérosexuels qu'elle
n'a même pas pensé à introduire la
définition du mariage qu'on est en
l'union d'un homme et d'une femme
eh bien nous allons jouer justement là
des dents nous allons essayer de faire
interpréter l'absence de définition du
mariage comme étant donc la porte
ouverte au mariage homosexuel
voici le c'est l'article qui restreint
le mariage l'homme avant 18 ans révolus
la femme avant 15 ans révolus ne peuvent
contracter mariage
seul l'âge est imposé l'hétérosexualité
du couple est seulement implicite
alors dans ce vide juridique s'engouffre
certains mais jacques ou plutôt par
exemple se dit prêt à marier des couples
du même sexe dans la mairie du 2e
arrondissement parisien
lorsqu on se marie on promet fidélité
secours et assistance à l'autre personne
du couple je crois qu'il est
discriminant d'interdire cette
possibilité à deux personnes qui
souhaitent le faire au prétexte qu'elle
serait du même sexe mais qu'ils soient
de droite ou de gauche peu de maires
acceptent l'idée de célébrer ce genre
d'union ses détracteurs mettent en avant
la vocation première du mariage est fait
pour les gens de sexe opposé
hétérosexuels qui veulent vivre ensemble
au crest
nous sommes je considère que c'est au
législateur de se prononcer aux etats
unis le maire de san francisco avait
exploité le même type de faille
juridique jusqu'à ce que la cour suprême
suspendent les mariages homosexuels
[Musique]